it's September but it's still so
damn
hi even Japanese people are like this
summer has been really really
intense
are you a fast food worker teacher
funeral
what there's oh it's your spirit at your
own funeral keep doing it keep doing it
flip the table
yeah
[Music]
what a mess all right nothing Bang
Fantastic game
got some German Chris Brown from my
Germans watching the Box
I know they waited for this shout out
let's try the German crisp bread fish
and bring on it
yeah
that was pretty good
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is your chance
I'm gonna tell Mommy
[Music]
thank you
people people people
you don't like the train
only in Japan
potato chocolate
I like them
my Tesla they're pretty good
we're underground deep underground
we're going uh trampoline Okay let's
jump
[Music]
I was gonna say that's why it's so good
beautiful no none of that healthy stuff
jumping was really fun trampoline thing
I did my first front flip I never done
it before when I was 14.
and we had a trampoline outside all the
other kids could do a front flip and I
could never do it
so I hope you're watching those stupid
14 year old kids because I can do it now
it's like I don't care
I'm in my boss chair
foreign
[Music]
you're a poofy boy yeah
say the tree
so much
hello today is
going to a beach we've been to before
it's really pretty ishiki beach you can
see my Fuji
no sir no waves on a Monday
[Music]
damn is there a party going on here
or did I walk into two traffic lights
it's gonna be good
oh no this is huge
this is huge
I went out to take out the trash and Mr
Frog is out there
just chilling by her don't say it I'm so
happy I got him some water he's gonna
have a little bath it's not scary
oh no he's gone oh there he is I spotted
him
dude I don't want to scare you
he's so well camouflaged but I saw him
walking here
I'm Just Gonna Leave You
a little bath
oh I saw him move right
yeah there he is you see him I don't
want to scare him
there we go we'll let you be
I got you water I'm so glad
you can live here forever I'm gonna 3D
print something
it's time to sleep
oh yeah
[Music]
we must demand more milk are you linked
from Zelda or an old lady were you
or you know
I think you're a garden now no way
oh that's so interesting
[Music]
we're in yamate in Yokohama we've been
here once before if you remember if
you're an OGE Vlog consumer thank you
Martha it's lovely
lovely I don't know what happened just
one day the weather decided to be like
you know what Summer's over
it's full now wish it is it's so nice
yeah
someday all of this will be yours here
hard time to
let's go and get some soft serve ice
cream she'll never find us again
she's only oh God
there's monsters in the woods spirit
[Music]
Hokkaido milk
I feel like he has too many thoughts and
he doesn't know how to act it
looks like I had to write do what I
wanted to do
[Music]
this is so lovely right beer he's
starting to cool so much best time to if
you want to visit Japan is probably now
in October not unbearably hot
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
foreign
I played it ages ago this is obscure
Japanese horror game like super small
Indie they had an exhibition
is riding the roller coasters there he
goes
laughs
I hijacked we're going to the exhibition
we're gonna go on roller coaster but
instead we're gonna watch art monster we
might have time for stuff we don't have
that much time today so it's from a game
called IB I played it back when I was in
Sweden it was one of the first nice
plays I've ever did I had like I can't
have I had more than 50 000 subscribers
myself still there
everyone loved it it was such a fun
let's play but the game was not very
popular but now it came out on Steam so
I think he got more popular but I hope
there's a big thank you PewDiePie sign
in the gallery if I'm curious to see it
head south super cool we're supposed to
head south thank you GPS this is a
really cool area
enjoy the lawn no one's enjoying it oh
quite a few people
it's a great game check out my let's
play guys
it's all down can you believe it I
didn't believe it that's crazy well we
weren't planning to go anyway so it
doesn't really matter damn I was
surprised to even see people there to be
honest as long as they have a PewDiePie
I imagine that there's a thank you
PewDiePie it's held me so loud thank you
[Music]
you're really good you have no reason to
be scared I mean you're not as good as
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I remember how wet we got last time it
was ridiculous Japan don't mess around
you're protected oh God I just saw this
blank you go in the front then yeah okay
I hid behind you as much as possible I
don't know how
did I get hit my shoes are soaked
how to get my shoes
there's a bad I can't talk yeah
I said I wish we were behind that car
because now we can look at ourselves
hello can you see this I'm waving I'm
showing my nipples
hey dance
Hey Yen yeah
it's your daddy I wanted to give a
little update we're at two months and
in two weeks it feels like we're through
the hardest bit at least I think the
first two months was definitely the
hardest especially since we you know we
were advised in Japan you're not
supposed to go outside you're trying to
figure everything out how everything
works how the baby works and
there's not much interaction either it
just feels a felt a bit like you're just
playing simulator like a boom Simulator
for him he doesn't give you much back
but now after the two month Mark he's
smiling you can read books for him he
gets happy to see you you can play with
him more it's more interactive you can
still let the first couple months
obviously but now it's just so much more
and you see his personality more it's
just really really fun so many people in
online are like oh the newborn stage
these are best I'm like I don't really
get it like now it's when it starts to
get fun right yarn I'm sleeping a lot
more too although it's Marcia letting me
sleep more it's coming at her expense
thank you Marcia yes Mommy is coming
soon yeah just very happy and everything
feels good
oh yeah and he tries to speak now right
sometimes he goes off in full-on
sentences
or like what
I'm making fun of you oh yeah that's the
end of the long thanks for watching I'll
see you guys in the next one